[Music]
john one of the things that has happened
uh with this surge in real estate is a
surge in real estate values
a lot of you are sitting on a home that
is worth a whole lot more
than it was uh 20 minutes ago than it
was two years ago it was three years ago
there was a big hurricane and i can't
remember the name of it that hit florida
and did massive destruction before
katrina hit new orleans so several years
back in other words
and after that hurricane
state farm made the decision
that they were no longer doing
policies that covered the value of the
house
instead they're going to do policies
homeowners policies that they state the
value
and the state farm is the biggest player
in the homeowners insurance world and so
everyone followed suit
and and sometimes some of the policies
uh you know whereas you buy a house for
300 000 bucks will make up a number and
you buy a homeowner's policy for 300 000
bucks cover the home you just bought
and it might have an inflation clause on
it that the next year it's a little bit
more next year it's a little bit more
but it would be
it would not be unusual for a whole
bunch of you listening right now
to have a home that you paid 300 for
that you've got 350 000 worth of
coverage with those inflation kickers on
them and the thing's worth 550 000 and
it burns down and you can't rebuild it
you can't build a driveway with 300
thousand dollars yeah yeah and so
what what i'm telling you is is that you
ha it is now incumbent upon you because
the insurance business changed as of
that hurricane that i can't remember the
name of uh the insurance business
changed and it's basically stated value
plus or minus inflation kickers and the
inflation kickers aren't enough wow and
so you have to
revisit
your homeowner's insurance once a year
and make sure you have the right amount
of coverage for the value of the house
how will you evaluate your your home on
an annual basis like that
i mean you can jump on just one of those
websites and look at it you're not going
to be far off but you kind of know
i got 189 000 worth of coverage and this
house is worth 600 grand our neighbors
just sold their house right yeah so you
know you're like way off yeah and so you
can toss that to your insurance provider
and they they'll they'll do a little
research on it and tell you what to
cover the house for but you need to
update your coverage because the value
of your home is growing
and your policy's not you know what
really freaks me out is the millions of
people who in 2020 and 2021
when the housing prices started to surge
took out a big home equity loan to pay
for their new bathroom they want to get
done during that gap and now
not only is the insurance coverage not
there
but they're going to be on the hook for
that that loan they're going to be
staring at a burn down lot holding a
check that can't replace the driveway
plus you owe me us this equity loan
exactly what a mess if you'd refinanced
the first mortgage they would have
required you to update the insurance but
many times a home equity loan doesn't
wow what a run this you're exactly right
so you could you could literally be
upside down on the house like like on an
old days old days in a car yeah that
kind of thing so what i'm telling you is
get online at
ramseysolutions.com and click the elp
for insurance and get a free quote on
your car insurance and your homeowners
insurance and keep your homeowner's
insurance updated
uh for the right amount of coverage
because if your house burns down and you
have 50 of it covered you're going to
build a very small house in that lot
i mean you're going to be screwed up and
if you've got a mortgage you know your
mortgage is probably less than that
you're gonna end up with nothing that's
zero you're gonna pay off the mortgage
and have a burned up lot yeah that's all
you're gonna have and so that's you're
gonna be in a mess so make sure you keep
your coverage up to date and always
price shop it with one of these uh
insurance brokers now the difference in
a broker
and somebody like state farm uh one of
these name brands uh you know if they've
got a uh
a celebrity endorser they're probably a
captive
company meaning state farm agents can
only sell state farm or a lizard
that's right that lizard thing that's
the other one yeah um and and so you can
you know
nationwide can only sell nationwide
and so you know that they they're
captive agents is what we call them in
the insurance business
so instead you want to get a broker that
will shop a bunch of different companies
and find you the best price in your
situation
and so many times when someone goes to
ramsey solutions.com clicks on the elp
and gets with an insurance broker and
shops they not only get the right amount
of coverage because their house has gone
up in value but they also get a cheaper
rate
and uh so if you're buying the same
amount of insurance a lot of people
fight to save seven eight hundred bucks
a year by changing their car and their
homeowners or auto and homeowners over
and um because they're just people are
we're fairly lazy
about our insurance shopping sure
uh we get it in place it's it's uh rip
it and forget it right i mean you just
put it on there and you pay the bill you
pay the pill you pay the bill unless
something comes up and shakes you up but
i'm telling you right now i don't know
what the percentage is but i would guess
north of 50 percent of you listening to
me right now that own a home do not have
the proper amount of coverage on your
home because your home's gone up in
value and you didn't update your
coverage
and the insurance companies do not
update it they are not they took that
responsibility
away from themselves and gave it to you
and having sat in this middle of the
street with somebody watching their
house burned down on a couple of
different occasions
that sounds like a nightmare on top of a
nightmare oh it is it's one of the most
horrible things to go through
emotionally and then on top of that to
not have the money to rebuild is just a
horrible thing so make sure you're
updating your insurance
ramseysolutions.com click on elp